we're back with Chloe Kardashian
all right so you shared this season that
you're training yourself to unlove your
ex um Tristan so just how'd you do that
asking for a friend
just I don't just if you have any paper
no it's hard I think it's the most
ridiculous thing sometimes like when
something doesn't work out and you're in
a relationship and you're so deeply in
love and people are like oh yeah why
can't you and I'm like I think I might
always still love that person I don't
know if that goes away no no I think it
goes away like my ex-husband I genuinely
still love and I want the best for him
and I'm rooting for him absolutely we
all I think just change or evolve or you
know that sometimes that's not it's just
not a bright fit for you yeah and what
when I said I'm learning how to unlove
Tristan I think people
whether it be family or friends or
anyone that you're telling your story to
yeah they're like okay so move on and
I'm like oh well let me find the switch
right like it's not that easy yeah just
even the habits that you built the
repetition the routine that when
something good happened I would call
Tristan or something bad or that's what
I did any little thing I would share my
life with him and so learning to just
reprogram myself like even though if
someone did something bad to me it
doesn't just mean I'm like there's a
wall and I built it up I know that this
isn't the right thing for me and I need
to slowly heal and move on but it
doesn't happen overnight no I I love
that and I love that you're open about
it because I am as well and I think in
theory too I I remember
um I feel like she said something like
you know it took you how long to fall in
love you know what I'm saying all those
steps so it's going to take you at least
that amount you know right to fall out
but I don't think it's the same for
everyone too and I think it's really
hard when you're in the public eye and
people judge the situation because it's
like you don't know the whole situation
you know you only see what are allowing
you to see right right and no one knows
the entire even I think sometimes our
close family and friends don't know the
whole situation yeah because we can be I
can be very like I'm very outgoing and
don't have a filter but like I can
filter yeah yeah and I think for me like
I've always been really proud of myself
the way that I'm still able to love
people even if they've wronged me and
I'm still able yeah but I how other
people are like oh you need like you
need to be more vindictive or get them
back or eye for an I'm just so not that
person like why I think it's a wasted
it's a waste of energy I really don't
care that much to respond in that way
that's literally what I say I don't care
that much it's just like a lot it seems
like a lot it's not my personality so
yeah why am I forcing myself to act away
I would never act on my own but also I
think it shows our kids so much I think
like we're allowed sometimes when people
hurt you it's not even personal and like
sometimes they're hurting and they don't
know it's more about that person and
we're all here to make mistakes we're
all on a journey of not perfection of
Journey of just figuring out our stuff
and sometimes people make mistakes that
are expense but I don't think that's a
reflection of me I think that's
definitely not that's how their journey
is and if I'm able to be strong enough
to endure it and say you know what
you're forgiven but I'm still going to
walk away but just show my kids that I
can still love someone that's made
mistakes I think that's a powerful thing
and for our yeah and for our kids to see
that and that's Everlasting Love and
that's a love that transcends to all
yeah areas of life and that's what kids
need to know is you can still love
people even if you're not I'm not
getting in love you're not getting
something in return I'm just want to
give you my love you shouldn't give to
get just give to give yeah it's a gift
agreed agreed
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
guys I'm going home